you know the one thing easing my butt
heartedness
is the fact that we're probably gonna
have work off tomorrow whoa I didn't
even think of that that's awesome
Welsh we are of course red death day
like a snow day but it's death there and
check this out I got a Swedish pen pal
in town she's in Vegas right now wants
to come to Hollywood which is where I
told her we live we don't smart I know I
can't say Rancho Cucamonga they don't
know what this they're from Sweden
they're not gonna know this we don't
know any you gotta say Hollywood hey
ders is this the same chick that you
told us about where you squeezed her
boob through her sleeve while watching
gladiator in the friends basement yeah
and it was a long-sleeved shirt so
where's my dog yeah I remember the
sleeve boo myself I'm taking the other
cheek too I apologize in advance for
marrying her whoa nice quick on the draw
step on the dip Samantha know about dab
actually but I'm gonna have to say no
because there's only one pure fair way
to decide who's gonna be my bro pilot on
this one yes hasten 87 okay okay that's
that's a pretty high bar blazer so that
means you only have to put on none
because I'm choosing you
oh you're serious I'm serious dude you
look like a professional skating
celebrity the Swedish chicks will dig
that yeah man bro skater I can do that
no problem Blake her has a death wish
well you should have thought about that
when you're putting spermicide on my
French crawler Oh doors rules Blake
let's step out of here
you